The greatest potential possessed by humans may be invention and innovation
Overcoming obstacles and changing the world around us
Such as the formation of language for example, which remains one of the greatest mysteries of scientists
Without a consensus on its beginnings, but without a doubt changed a world
The sex of quasi-humans who existed nearly 2.5 million years ago. Or ability to control
With evidence of cooked food dating back to about 1.5 million years.
About 200,000 years ago, modern humans evolved, but after 190,000 years
We turned from fishing communities and started farming
Collecting grains, planting them and paying attention to them is not the form of our modern civilization.
Soon after, the plow was invented, changing the agriculture
By 5000 BC we began to feel more curious towards the planet and invented sailboats
Thus opening the world of exploration. In 3500 BC the first glasses were invented, and after 100 years
The nails that are found in ancient Egypt come to help us make a better building,
Which have helped expand human life. A few centuries later cement was invented
It is the basis for our urbanization, literally.
Considering the improvement of transportation, the wheel was invented in 3000 BC followed by
With soap and then the primitive computer, or abacus
Which has helped to increase people's capabilities and shape our economy. Although the paper
It was not made until 200 BC and the printing press until 1430 AD, but the first libraries
Appeared in 2600 BC with recorded recordings on stone slabs to make knowledge
By 1500 BC, the alphabet became popular in some societies
As a synonym for glyphs, is causing further cognitive transmission
700 years later, the modern 9-9 system emerged, paving the way for mathematics.
The first democracy began in Greece in 508 BC, where everyone had an equal share
In power, it is possible that our favorite innovation is scientific method.
Which arose at the time of Aristotle in 384 BC - a process requiring information and verification in new phenomena -
We may be slightly biased, of course it has been refined over time.
The Chinese invented the first compass in 300 BC, allowing sailors to sail
For vast distances, and at the same time designed the Archimedes spiral which helps in the transfer
Water from low to high areas, making irrigation and agriculture. And all this even before
The present era.
Speaking of time, the first mechanical clock came in 725 AD but was not even
In 1582, when the Gregorian calendar was established, it was the time of the people around the world
The glasses came in the thirteenth century and may look slim but overly elevated
Human intelligence, and it has also been a sign of binocular and microscopy
Before the telescope, in 1542, it was the idea that Earth was not the center of the universe
Pioneer, but the Copernicus system put the sun into the axis of the solar system
And all, this has not been accepted for hundreds of years.
At the end of 1600 AD steam engines came and were not only used for trains, ships, even factories
The problem of the industrial revolution, which was later replaced by internal combustion engines.
At about the same time, binary figures and Bolian logic developed
Which is the basis of digital computing, Newton's laws
The movement and general intrigue helped shape the ideas of physics despite Einstein's theory
Special relativity and general quantum theory as well
These ideas were then built.
Vaccines came in 1796, which over the past twenty years only saved 21 million people from hospital for treatment
And prevented 732,000 people from dying, water purification and food preservation as well
I saved millions of lives, and the camera allowed us to document
Our past and connect with the events of the present. Hundreds of years to come will also witness tremendous development
In communication with telegraph and telephone, radio waves,
Radio, and television, all converted
Our world makes it seem smaller.
The world of medicine changed radically in 1846 with the appearance of anesthesia,
And antiseptic, which allowed major surgeries that were previously very painful
Thus saving innumerable lives. Sewage system also has a good range of spread
Many diseases. Refrigeration also changed the way people eat around the world
The invention of the lighting lamp occurred shortly after that note
Static electricity was in 600 BC, and the invention of electric condenser
In 1745 it was like many other discoveries that paved the way for the use of electricity
The move was a giant step by step in 1885 by modern car, and later
Aircraft, semiconductors that will help regulate the flow of electricity
And finally transport resistance, without which the modern electronic devices will not work
Many scientific discoveries will be followed initially by the electron
Which helped Niels Bohr model his work for the atom, although the atom
Her theory was actually developed 2,300 years ago. Nitrogen fixation,
Plant breeding has helped us to maintain our society and its credit for conservation
The same billion along with antibiotics such as penicillin, accidental discovery
Fighting bacterial infection, birth control also reduced the number of children
In women allowing higher quality life, polyethylene and other plastics
All of us surround us in many of our influences.
The discovery of DNA in the 1950's unleashed many of what we now know about humanity
Through inherited traits and genetics, resulting in genetic engineering
And the sequence of succession in the seventies, and in the past eighty years, communication jumped
Steps forward from satellite communications in the 1940s
TV, weather, defense and to the beginning of the Internet
1960s, PC and GPS in the 1970s, without mentioning the device
Which could be in your hands or in your pocket now a smartphone that is invented
For the first time by IBM in 1994.
As technology continues to progress here on Earth, space exploration continues to astonish us
The first successful orbital launch in 1957, the first landing on the moon
In 1969 and the Hubble Space Telescope in the 1990s, both a spacecraft
An observatory scouring the earth every 97 minutes.
But, the more we look at the universe and the future
What will come next? As sometimes the world may seem dark, these innovations
Show that people live longer, healthier, and happier.
One of the best ways
To ensure the continuity of innovation is to support leaders who recognize the importance of programs
General research of global health, agriculture, information technology or energy.
You can find out more about the innovations in the amazing Bill Gates blog that funded this episode
Learn more about what we can do to make sure that the world continues to improve for all
There is a link to his blog in the description
Subscribe to the weekly scientific sections Translation team translated @Autrjim